[Music]
this week Council held its monthly
meeting for May after receiving a verbal
submission on the long-term plan from
local resident mr. Robert Johnston the
council moved into receiving reports
first up was a regeneration report on
proposed reaching and the kuiper River
the council authorized staff to proceed
with design consenting and work
programming of dredging there will
increased navigability along the
Khoikhoi River particularly at low tide
dredging is also planned for the north
side of the river near the Williams
Street bridge this will allow for the
installation of floating pontoons
alongside the Riverview terraces that
are currently under construction Council
approved the design and layout of the
pontoons and staff will now put the
purchase of the pontoons themselves out
to team down
the council also expressed its support
for environment Canterbury's plans to
fill gaps in the secondary stop bank
along the Ashley River as part of this
work weekend we'll be raising both cones
Road and Milton Avenue approximately
three meters and that work is expected
to take place later this year although
traffic diversions will be in place
during the roadworks access to nearby
facilities such as the dog park and BMX
track will be maintained as well as
access to the ashley bridge itself the
project will be fully funded by
Environment Canterbury following
community consultation the Waimakariri
District Council's stormwater drainage
and water course protection bylaw 2018
was adopted the bylaw has a range of
provisions that aim to protect our
stormwater and drainage infrastructure
mitigate flooding hazards and safeguard
the environment against the discharge of
contaminants it also makes clear to
landowners their responsibilities around
drains in waterways
the council has also approved a draft
submission to the upcoming government
policy statement on land transport the
submission is seen as an important
opportunity for the council to present
its views about the new government's
proposals for priorities and investment
and land transport in our submission we
expressed our support for more public
transport options for the Greater
Christchurch area and we strongly
advocated for the continuation of the
proposed NZTA wooden bypass the next
monthly council meeting will be at the
council chambers in longi order on
tuesday 5th of june at 1 p.m.
[Music]